what if i told you that all of this was
already admitted to
by previous united states presidents
you're talking about barack obama barack
obama said
he said the aliens won't let it happen
you will reveal
all of their secrets they exercise
strict control over us let me
let me let me reenact exactly what obama
said he was having a very very serious
and important conversation with one of
our great american thought leaders
jimmy kimmel yes and he said the aliens
won't let it happen
you have you you you will reveal all
their secrets they have strict
can they exercise strict control over us
right with obama so he was like uh
you will reveal your secrets i'm kidding
it was a gag
bit he did say it but you take the quote
out of context and yes
people think it's real so actually this
is funny this is a ufo website
where they're like obama said the aliens
won't let it happen
they exercise strict control and he's
laughing and then jimmy kimmel says
now there's going to be people who
analyze everything you say and how you
looked when you said it
because it was a joke that's true and
bill clinton made a similar comment as
well and again some of these things are
legitimate
legitimately jokes but there are some
serious implications just like with
china
china literally built the largest radio
dish
and telescope so they could try to
communicate with aliens you look up
well hold on yeah and then if it's true
the aliens are here why would they build
it
maybe they're not talking to the chinese
maybe the chinese know something that we
don't know about but they're spending a
tremendous amount of money
they're saying for aliens i don't know
maybe they don't like how
the you know the chinese are doing gene
splicing right now to build super
soldiers which
maybe that's allegedly happening uh from
an article that
just was released a couple days ago who
knows i have no idea no one really knows
until we get more answers from the
government that clearly is
lying about it and uh we need more i
don't know man
have you had did you listen to the 9am
cnn tapes from project veritas
no so uh you heard about this right ian
lydia no yeah i think so
yeah project veritas has recorded the 9
a.m phone calls from cnn
yeah this this is relevant trust me what
you learn
is that there is no grand conspiracy
just bumbling morons
you get the president of cnn jeff zucker
being like so um today i think man you
know tucker carlson's a racist
and uh maybe that's we we should talk
about that and they're like i really
agree you know he's very racist
and you'd think hearing this call it's
jessica being like
all right everyone listen today we're
going to frame tucker carlson we're
going to accuse him of no it was
he literally believes it it's just a
bunch of morons talking about their dumb
[ __ ] stuff
well they're supporting their special
interest at the end of the day and they
make sure that they never bite the hand
that feeds them now it might not be such
a sophisticated
complex thing like we see in major think
tanks that usually provide all the
talking points but
we do see it as a pretty effective
regurgitating machine
that just does what it's told and maybe
there's no orders top down but maybe
they just have the individuals that
believe in what they believe in that are
on the same page you know you want to
know why i'll i'll be honest with you i
don't think aliens
come here is that maybe they do but it's
like
i was watching this video about life and
it was really really interesting
perspective
they said think about the evolutionary
distance between a human being
and an ant it's like a billion years or
something like that
but still infinitely closer
in you know uh like how we function and
thrive and the fuels we use and the air
and things like that than an alien race
on a planet that was say
all water or you know a different you
know chemical composition
but more importantly they said think
about the difference between a human and
a dog
humans and dogs actually communicate
very well
for inter-species relationship dogs can
learn words in english can especially
really smart ones like border collies
but you can never explain to a dog what
a suit what a highway is
you can't explain to a dog what an
international trade route is
you can explain to the dog loud noise
scary car hurt
very simple things now think about an
advanced species
that is able to travel you know beyond
the speed of light or interdimensionally
or whatever
why would they try and communicate with
something infinitely separated from us
that's why you gotta take mushrooms my
buddy
my buddy's dog accidentally got into a
bag of his mushrooms
it got really smart it realized it was a
dog and it would get it would like
really get angry at us when we didn't
treat it you don't know what it knew
well you can't read it personally okay
let's stop talking about mushroom dogs
here but i just i i disagree with you
and i do believe that there are aliens i
think that why
i think especially from the video
footage we saw that was released of that
unidentified flying object that was
defying the laws of physics defying
but that could be it could be a telstra
military um
maybe that's also we didn't know about
nuclear weapons
when it comes to this israeli professor
when it comes to paul heller
sitting down with them looking them in
the eyes these are old individuals who
have nothing to lose
who just i think we're at the highest
elements of government that are now
on their death bed trying to get as much
information out there to
to you can't afford to listen i mean you
know i i agree what i'm saying is when
you're at that age they got nothing over
you exactly
what are they gonna threaten you with
exactly so i think that adds an extra
layer of credibility to some of their
allegations this israeli professor said
this and i think i'm gonna i'm just
gonna quote him directly because i think
this is important
he said quote if i had come up with what
i'm saying today five years ago
i would have been hospitalized whenever
i've gone with this
in academia they said the man has lost
his mind
today they're already talking
differently i have nothing to lose i
received my degrees and awards i am
respected in universities abroad
where the trend is also changing i'm
happy this trend is changing it needs to
change a little bit more
it's fun to joke about but we need more
information we need more accountability
what the hell is the government hiding
from us because they have a lot that
don't know
weapons let me let me let me tell you
something very very simple right
how many planets exist that have the
identical chemical composition to earth
a lot identical oh identification
probably zero
similar that we know about in the fact
that we know about and based on
calculations
they're i think it's fair to say a lot
but what is a lot relative to
the you know 40 10 000 or something
maybe
right now think about this would life
so there's there's two ideas here alien
life could look like who knows what
it could be a gigantic pulsating mass
with like a thousand little tentacle
arms
it wouldn't necessarily look like a
human or have arms or legs
think about a dolphin right really smart
no hands
and underwater they can't create fire to
manipulate elements to create
any kind to break things things down and
create circuits and build
dolphins never gonna build a rocket ship
it's not possible so you have to think
about
there's actually an argument for why
aliens would probably
if they did exist like our planet the
chemical composition allows us to
manipulate elements to create computers
and and rockets and things like that
and other kind of technology that you
can't do in a water or atmosphere that
maybe would ignite instantly
so that means there may be a bunch of
aliens really smart ones and a bunch of
other planets
that can't do anything can never leave
or maybe their technology is
just they can only get to a certain
level but then if you look at where
we're at
it's possible because we have rocketry
that there will be another you know
alien species
that came from very similar conditions
where they had uh the right amount of
oxygen in the atmosphere like a great
fire
allowing them to separate elements out
and then do electrolysis and things like
that
however what if we are actually the
aliens
trapped in the oxygen atmosphere and the
other super advanced aliens live in this
crazy planet
where they can better access and
manipulate all the different elements
and they look at us like dolphins who
are trapped forever and you've never
seen
panspermia that no the universe is
seeded um basically by life
that's the star trek lore and that like
a fungal spores which can exist in deep
space
and survive were sent throughout the
universe for whatever reason and landed
in our oceans and then
evolved over time started to eat other
fungus and became animal and that's kind
of
uh we're instead of evolutions we're
actually adaptations of that life form
for this environment it's like
prometheus so you're saying the earth is
not flat
yes that's basically where i was going
that's nice of it
it's it's a it's a concave bowl right is
that is that the actual theory with a
turtle on it yeah no no they say that
when people say the earth is flat it's
actually got a ridge around it of ice
so it's it's the firmament it's a bowl
it's it's a bowl and so it collects
the little space dust and the little
fungus comes and rains down and i like
that
you know what i love about flat earth do
you know how they think gravity works
no they think you got a stinkbug on your
mic
they think that the uh the flat earth is
exponentially speeding up
moving upward oh it's just sucking us
down
and that mathematically the speed will
never stop you know tell me that
one more time i was looking at the bug
they believe that that the earth is
exponentially moving faster in an upward
direction
oh that's pointing us down yeah we could
also be falling
in the entire universe that we perceive
could be falling at the same speed
and we wouldn't know because it was all
relative that's a better way to put it
we're upside down falling and we're
standing on it just like
anyway so i think what's happened is
octopi
humans you know our brain stem creature
that is inside this saltwater sac
is like an alien well the brain stem is
salt water so i think that
we're all kind of alien life forms that
were seeded to earth but
these craft that are flying around are
like tesla lightweight aluminum craft
that the government co-opted from his
laboratory and is
secretly lying to us and telling us that
it's aliens throw us off the trail
but i could make up a million one things
you know what i mean we could keep going
all night here right right
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you
all next time
you